Huawei a massive distributor forcing its
way into the west tech industry and
shaking up relations between China
Europe and America when it comes to
trade security and surveillance to
telecom giant Vodafone found security
flaws in Huawei British intelligence
based in that building behind me has
warned of serious risks to UK operators
while we can create a back tour to China
for years it and the Chinese government
have been accused of intellectual
property theft a number of reasons why
they say Huawei is not to be trusted the
UK Prime Minister Boris Johnson has
tried to strike a balance when it comes
to our way in its 5g network on Huawei
and and 5g I don't want this country to
be unnecessarily hostile to investment
from from overseas on the other hand we
cannot prejudice our vital national
security interest but a day later Boris
Johnson calls a stir when he visited the
set of a British morning television show
and snaps selfies with the two hosts
using a Huawei phone
[Music]
the television host said that the phone
belonged to Boris Johnson leading to
some to speculate whether the fact the
Prime Minister uses a Chinese model
represents some sort of security
vulnerability however Johnson's aides
said that the phone was borrowed from
staffers and casually put into his very
own pocket for whatever the truth is
Huawei won't mind the extra free
publicity at all and they and other
Chinese firms are making quite great
strides in Western markets as for
November this year Huawei has become the
third most popular phone in the UK with
almost 10 percent of the market share
with the UK planning of course to leave
the European Union all attention will
turn to securing as much investment from
countries around the world as possible
so was Boris Johnson's move a big 5g
signal
you